we can't keep testing ourselves whole
our lives news the pre-arrival coveted
test requirement will soon be scrapped
as welcomed by these travelers i think
it's all good to get back to normal i'm
so excited to hear that global news has
confirmed the government is set to
announce a pcr or antigen test will no
longer be required for those entering
canada by land or by air businesses
airline and travel industries have been
lobbying for the change for some time
calling it a non-science based obstacle
for a lot of business travelers
having those pre-departure tests has
been just another barrier that's made it
more difficult for either canadians to
go travel abroad or to have people's you
know foreign customers come into canada
most medical professionals agree the
sensitivity of a rapid test is obviously
quite limited so it was more of a
symbolic thing than anything else once
you sort of move away from pcr testing
there are other rules expected to stay
in place random testing for incoming
travelers and the requirements to be
fully vaccinated and use the arrivecan
app which makes sense for surveillance
purposes right because there will
probably unfortunately be new variants
for those who may be nervous the virus
is not gone on vacation or is still
around so i prefer to know people who
come in is
tested negative experts say the risk of
contracting covet in the air is low with
airlines continuing to request masking
for everybody on the flight and with
ensuring that people who are traveling
have vaccine certification to show that
they're fully vaccinated i think the
addition of pre-travel testing is
actually the least effective
the announcement could come as early as
thursday abigail beeman global news
ottawa